ladies and gentlemen it's time for the
Friday mailbag you can email into info
davidpackman.com sometimes in addition
to emails we'll feature a tweet a
Facebook message a YouTube comment
something else and I want to start today
with a Facebook message and one of the
things every once in a while I try to do
it's a very dangerous thing to do it's a
very fraught thing to do I will try to
engage with a troll or just a nut
and last time I did this it was an
anti-vaxx person and I actually said hey
let's let's talk to them let's figure
out how they came to believe the things
they believe and I asked some questions
and it was all very weird and it went
nowhere and we learned very little I
tried again the other day this is
someone that sent in a message via
Facebook
Stanley said we found fraud attached to
you you need to come clean with your
listeners about your scam
so I wrote back great please send the
information of Fraud and we will come
clean no idea what you're talking about
offhand
so they write back and they say I'm
sending it to the faculty license
department
what's that and then they said the FCC
Department
to which I explained again this is an
experiment to see where it goes I said
we aren't governed by the FCC the FCC
doesn't govern the internet let us know
the fraud so that we can investigate
to which Stanley said yes you are you're
of course it's the wrong your your
broadcasting which fall in FCC
regulations and your rangior a
subscriber Channel as well which falls
into monies changing hands
and I said money's Changing Hands is
under the purview of the FTC not the FCC
can you let us know the fraud so we can
investigate and correct it to which I
never heard back so another exercise in
the futility of trying to substantively
engage
with the trolls
next the email is from Patrick Patrick
is very angry with me
Patrick says hi David
I thought you were an independent
thinker I can't understand you praising
Biden he doesn't know who he is where he
is or who his wife is surely you know
this man is a threat to our country and
should be impeached for the open borders
alone now remember there has been
essentially no change in Border policy
between Trump and Biden
just we stopped pretending that we're
building a wall that's the difference
also I'm sure you know because you were
smart that he is being used as a puppet
for Obama
rice and Clane
very obvious actual people running the
country you were too young but the Biden
family has been corrupt over 40 years
and should be prosecuted funny you never
talk about the Biden laptop
you were better off supporting Bernie
Sanders good luck so this is like it's
got to be presented without comment
because there's about a dozen things in
there that don't make any sense but this
is someone who believes
that they know a lot
and that they're really smart and this
is what we're up against how do you talk
sense into someone like Patrick or DL I
don't know they signed their email DL
even though it came from Patrick it's
very difficult to do
Dale wrote in and said
ouch David you just called Native
Americans American Indians
ouch so listen first of all I didn't
call them that I I was reading poll
results
and the poll referred to
American Indians and Alaska natives okay
I use whatever term I understand to be
the correct term there was a time about
a decade ago when it was wrong to say
American Indian and you were only
supposed to say Native American
now if you Google it increasingly what
you find is that either term is
appropriate Native American or American
Indian
I have no preference one way or the
other I'm just using the terms that uh
are are being determined to be
appropriate but I I was literally
reading a poll it wasn't a term I came
up with Dale so see if you can relax a
little bit on that Lisa wrote in about
watering times we talked about
restrictions on when you're allowed to
water your lawn in different places and
Lisa said David on the bonus show you
talked about water use restrictions you
may find it interesting to know that in
New Mexico where it is hot and dry in
the summer we have restrictions on the
time of day during which you were
allowed to water your lawn or outdoor
plants due to the rapid rate of
evaporation during Peak daylight hours
which leads to Water waste that makes a
lot of sense and I know so little about
this that I didn't realize that some of
the restrictions are based on that but
that makes a lot of sense and many such
examples of people writing in with
comments like Lisa's Josh wrote in about
my interview with Republican Mike
cargile and Josh said hey David how do
we know Mike cargile isn't the
demon-possessed one prior to your
interviews with him I didn't believe in
demon possession but surely a
demon-possessed person would sound
exactly like Mark Mark Mike cargile
where do they find these people it is
beyond me
that interview with Mike cargile
triggered such a reaction from the
audience if you haven't seen it check it
out he
tells us who he believes are the
demon-possessed people it's mostly
blacks and Jews that he names which I
pointed out to him
um it's a wild interview and it is
shocking that folks like this exist it
really is it was eye-opening eye-opening
for lack of a better term
Mika wrote in and said hey David I was
thinking about the story that Fred Trump
was humored into believing he still ran
the Trump organization when he had
Alzheimer's how he went to the office
every day to sign blank papers and talk
to a decoy secretary not now knowing
that Donald Trump kept those classified
documents argued they belonged to him
refused to give them back even kept some
of them in his desk it's almost like
props to play president on top of all
the rightful president stolen election
future reinstatement nonsense the
parallel is amusing how much of the
narrative is griffed and how much is
delusion I used to think all Griff but
I'm not sure anymore regards Mika yeah
it's a good question I made this analogy
earlier in the week the idea of trump
in a sort of Truman Show similar to his
own father when his father had
Alzheimer's at this point I don't even
pretend to know I genuinely don't know
how much is grift and how much is
delusion but it seems as though it's it
seems as though it's not a hundred
percent either it's some mix of the two
um I got an email about latinx
David I heard your explanation of why
latinx is imposed by white progressives
and that it is not used by Latino and
Latina people well that may be the case
within your circles the use of the
ending with x is a way for queer folk of
romantic languages to express and
address each other you can see that in
the US with the onset of MX to replace
Mr and Mrs full disclosure I am a queer
white Progressive however within my
social media circles and physical spaces
people of all Origins Filipino European
South America latinx is commonplace
because even Latino Latina is exclusive
I would be curious if you have any
statistical data to back up your view on
the term I can only speak from my
experience yeah I mean when you actually
look at surveys of Latinos for example
there's a 2019 survey National survey of
Latinos found only three percent of and
again here you can use whatever term you
want to use his Hispanics Latinos only
three percent of Hispanic slash Latinos
have ever ever used the term latinx
ever three percent of Latinos okay the
league of United Latin American citizens
announced in 2021 they're going to stop
using latinx because almost all Latinos
don't like it and don't use it so it is
widely documented that almost no actual
Latino folks use
latinx by the way you should see there's
this whole other thing I don't even know
that I want to get into this but
there's this whole other thing where
in Spanish words are gendered in that
for example if we talk about the word
friends which the singular is Amigo okay
the plural would be Amigos or Amigas
if you say amigos it's either a group of
male friends or a mixed group
men and women if you say Amigas with an
a it's understood that it's a group of
female friends this is this is the
language okay this exists in you know
French that this is the way it is in
Spanish there's a new thing that has
come up which is they replace instead of
an o or an e
the neutral I'm sorry I I just said that
wrong instead of an o or an A you
instead use an e so instead of Amigos or
Amigas it's amigues
and it is another thing which
I I don't do
and which is similar to latinx that has
started to sort of pervade the language
and um anyway maybe a topic for another
day but there's my data those two
studies that I cited next email from
Sonia Sonia is really angry that I said
I'm not a cat guy it's not a big deal
some people aren't Badger people some
people aren't into rhinos some people
are against HIPAA I'm sorry against
hippos sorry now I got confused
um Sonia says David sir love the show
Proud subscriber you're an educated
articulate and a student you are
educated articulate and astute it's
refreshing to watch your show and know
without a doubt that like-minded
progressives still exist but
I lost some respect for you when you
recently said you don't like cats there
is a rule amongst cat lovers that says
if you meet a person who doesn't like
cats run the other way I ascribe to this
in my personal relationships but it will
certainly not deter me from your show
you may think of me as a crazy cat lady
she says she's 60 but I've Loved cats
and all animals my entire life you're a
father now you never know what surprises
are in store I hope that one day you
will be blessed with the love of a cat
listen this is not
I I don't hate cats I don't Advocate
violence against cats I'm just not a cat
guy you know I I like dogs
I like uh you know I like
zebras I don't know I'm just not a cat
guy it's not a big deal
and no offense to anybody that owns cats
Jared said hey David wanted to message
you to say thanks for your Finance
section on your website I picked up a
couple of the books I'm in my final
semester of college don't know much
about Finance but the selection you
provided looked perfect just wanted to
say thanks yeah listen if you want my
list of uh recommendations for personal
finance books you can find it at
davidpackman.com Finance many such
people have found it interesting
Jonathan wrote In
and Jonathan says hey David you
mentioned on a call that colleges are
prepared to pay handsomely for
conservatives like Ben Shapiro but not
for progressives that doesn't fit with
the image of colleges being heavily
skewed to the left you know
post-modernist Marxist blah blah what
have I missed yeah listen without
delving at all into the academic biases
of colleges what I can tell you is
uh most of the speakers that go to
college campuses and are paid
are paid by groups not by the college
itself it's not like the department of
Poli SCI pays for Ben Shapiro to speak
at a school and the on-campus right-wing
groups are way better funded you know
there's these groups students for
Liberty and I'm making that up there's a
dozen or so groups the groups are way
better funded on the right than on the
left and so that's why in my experience
the money is way better for right wing
campus speakers than for left-wing
campus speakers my experience my
experience and I'm glad to be uh pointed
in a different direction you can email
in info davidpackman.com if you have
something to say and remember
919 September 19th we have a fantastic
one day membership special that we will
be doing if you have been thinking maybe
I'll get a membership I don't know
sounds interesting get on my newsletter
at davidpackman.com and then on the
Monday of September 9 on the morning of
September 19th you will get a beautiful
email telling you how to sign up at a
historically
humiliatingly low price all right see
you then or on today's bonus show